[Music]
the newest hero an overwatch has arrived
in well usually I'll say something cool
here introducing them but what the hell
I'm just gonna get straight to the point
it's hamster and a giant rolling ball
neck
[Music]
specimen eight known to most as ham in
the hamster pilots a mechanical ball
that he himself built equipped with tons
of firepower and defensive abilities
that would make IRISA cry and as
ridiculous as he may seem breaking ball
which is both the name of his mech and
his official in-game title is a
powerhouse tank that deserves to be
taken seriously trust me oh look he's
got a little trackball to move the mech
around so cute first things first
you've got wrecking balls primary fire
the quad cannons they're your typical
machine gun fit for a tank as they'll do
average damage at close range and pretty
terrible damage from afar so nothing
really special here your main focus
though is gonna be elsewhere you're
gonna want to learn how to traverse the
terrain with him as his first ability is
the role Hammond can change in and out
of the role at any time and it allows
him to move the wrecking ball at a
faster speed and faster you'll want to
go as the secondary fire is the
grappling claw much like widow-makers
hook you can attach it to any surface
and start using it to speed up and swing
your massive body all over the place
gained enough speed as indicated by the
glow on the ball and you can ram into
enemies knocking them back now you'll
really have to practice with it in order
to get the angles and physics just right
but once you do you'll be spinning
around payloads knocking everyone around
or launch yourself into the air to get
to platforms that other tanks would
struggle to reach and once you're high
up you can come crashing back down to
earth with wrecking balls other
offensive ability piledriver as long as
you're at least 10 metres in the air you
can slam back down earth dealing 100
damage and knocking everyone around you
straight up it's a great move to begin a
push as you can activate his defensive
ability right afterwards the adaptive
shield okay
this ability is secretly the best
defensive move in the game and nobody
knows it like except you and me and
everyone else who watches this video but
when you activate it it gives the
wrecking ball a temporary barrier of 100
health and it will multiply depending on
how many enemies are within range that
means if you activate it in the middle
of an entire team you wind up with 1,200
health enough to withstand even the
deadliest of burst damage
wait did I say that his shield is his
best offensive ability I really meant
his ultimate wrecking balls final
ability is his mine field which spits
out over a dozen proximity mines around
the mech it's a great way to claim a
point or deny access to a bottleneck
area as intruders will be subject to
detonation the second they walk across
the mines now keep in mind the mines can
be destroyed and they can also be
avoided by more mobile characters but
the damage you can inflict on the poor
souls that happen to run across them
more than makes up for it with all these
tools you'll be well equipped to handle
anything the opposing team might throw
at you if you're looking for a quick
flowchart though you can swing into the
fray land a piledriver on top of the
enemy heroes activate your adaptive
shield shoot your quad cannons and
hopefully hopefully survive long enough
to grapple away to safety rinse repeat
you know the drill that's kind of the
super basic idea for specifics though
you'll want to approach slowly and
either use your grappling hook to bash
enemies when they get too close for
comfort or to swing away to your healer
when your health gets low his role by
the way will reload your primary weapon
after a couple seconds so it's best to
stay in that form as often as you can
piledriver is a good way to get in and
surprise your opponents just be aware
that the move knocks them upward as well
so make sure your team adjusts their aim
accordingly
and since wrecking balls adaptive shield
has the potential to make them
incredibly sturdy you'll want to be
selective when using it
I'd recommend laying off the button
until they're at least maybe two or
three or even four opponents surrounding
you but if you find yourself with low
health and no heals that extra barrier
from the single enemy can save you from
certain death
wrecking ball is a hero unlike any other
an overwatch but if you can master the
hamsters physics based approach and
situational defensive abilities he's a
force that will definitely live up to
his name
hey thank you all for watching this
video if you guys have any other tips or
strategies for him and make sure to
leave them in the comments below and
don't forget to check out all 27 of the
other overwatch hero guides that we have
wow that's actually kind of a lot of
idios but if you're just getting started
with overwatch make sure you check them
out and we will see you all on the next
hero guide
[Music]
you
[Music]